meryloquette est athlète de haut niveau
de parabadminton quatrième mondial de la
catégorie joueur debout avec un handicap
d'un membre supérieur il vise maintenant
la qualification aux Jeux paralympiques
de Paris 2024 avec plus d'une dizaine de
pays parcourus à l'année avec la
Fédération Française de Badminton ou en
famille les quatre coins du globe n'ont
plus de secret pour lui c'était cet
hiver en décembre ça se voit il fait
froid c'était à la Réunion et j'ai fait
le Piton des Neiges pour voir déjà un
jour faire les jeux c'est un truc de
dingue et en plus de faire le tour du
monde de décorer
en fait le monde quoi les gens la
culture c'est un truc de fou c'est
souvent des phrases bateaux ouais
j'adore pour la culture
sur plein de trucs c'est une ouverture
d'esprit que je kiffe vraiment c'est
trop bien atteindre une agénésie au bras
droit mais il n'en fait pas une
contrainte lors de ses voyages au
contraire à Bali il y a beaucoup de
espèce de petites mobylette et c'est les
choses de trucs que je peux pas faire en
fait j'ai pris un genre d'élastique
comme ça là que j'ai mis autour de
l'accélérateur j'ai mis ma main dedans
et en fait avec la pression d'élastique
ça a serré l'accélérateur et dès que je
faisais ça ça accéléré du coup c'est de
la débrouille mais j'ai trop kiffé même
si certains obstacles s'imposent de même
pour lui ou son équipe
on était en Ouganda en Afrique et
pas d'ascenseur pas de rampe donc à
chaque petite étape je devais être là
pour soit soulever le fauteuil soit le
lever prendre le fauteuil le remettre
sur le fauteuil parce que en fait tout
était une épreuve et là je me suis rendu
compte que waouh c'est chiant quoi c'est
hyper galère
au niveau de la vision des gens et de
leur mentalité elle est très différente
dans les pays par contre asiatiques
les pays arabes et tout donc c'est le
regard de l'handicap n'est pas le même
je pourrais pas te dire si c'est positif
ou négatif mais en tout cas il y a un
regard qui est qui pèse un peu malgré
les difficultés mériles portent un
regard optimiste sur le handicap et son
accessibilité je peux tout faire
je trouve que il y a plus trop de
limites à avoir dans tous les domaines
qui soient quand on a un handicap je
trouve quand même le monde il évolue
dans la mentalité dans l'adaptation de
tout il y a un peu de retard dans
certains pays dans certains continents
mais en général si on s'y prend un peu à
l'avance si on réfléchit un petit peu il
y a pas de souci dans sa course pour les
Jeux Olympiques de Paris 2024 Meryl doit
affronter une dizaine de tournois
partout dans le monde sa prochaine
destination le Brésil dans deux semaines